with Robin she's like made it very clear
that she no longer sees herself like as
a part of the family sister wife star
Gwendolyn Brown doesn't have high hopes
for a family reunion I think the whole
dream of reuniting the family is so
lovely and so cute but at this point I'm
not sure if Robin can be reunited with
it the 21 year old daughter of Cody
Brown and his ex Christine filmed her
final YouTube recap of season 17 and
gets real about her dad's only remaining
wife Robin
what she wanted was the family and that
she wanted us all to be together from
day one and here he is no longer with
these other three women with these other
13 children she just lost that it's not
the future I wanted
Gwendolyn explains why she doesn't see a
family get-together happening anytime
soon we all live far apart and it would
be awesome to have a big Christmas
together again I'm not sure if she'll
allow that to happen with her kids
you're having to look at your
relationships a little bit closer
but how they move forward as a family is
something Robin previously said she'd
never decide for her kids we went
through a process of deciding
individually if this is what we wanted
and you know we all had our own
testimony we all gained our own
testimony of being in the family and
living this way and we would never take
we would never take that away from our
children like they need to find their
own path and their own belief and in
order to you know live their fullest
life
so for us plural marriage doesn't work
for us marriage doesn't work Cody was
married to both Robin and Christine as
well as two other women Janelle and Mary
now the latter three women have moved on
it's taken all of us to create the world
we're in as I unravel it it seems that
who I am unraveling this with
each each one this unravels to the point
where I'm like I I am getting kind of in
Dark Places the timing for me to leave
was just it opened up and everything
became just things fell into place once
I decided to just I kind of looked at
where my life was and before I decided
to leave and I'm like do I really want
to do this for another 10 years and
gwendolyn's fully supporting her mom I
was like you're leaving good for you she
told me that she was moving and also
divorcing my father at like the same
time so I was like all hyped for her I
didn't really love the relationship that
they had and she's doing really great
now but one thing she's realizing with
her YouTube rewatch series she's
separating her real life from the
televised version of her fam when I
watch the show sometimes I forget that I
I'm I'm like one of these people and I
watch it I'm like this completely
separate person which is probably not a
good idea because when you're watching
show and you see these people as like
people on TV you start to see them less
human and Morris entertainment and
that's not a good way to think about my
parents
foreign